in the middle of all that icy weather in
Memphis the family of Tyree Nichols is
preparing for his funeral this morning
yesterday alongside civil rights leader
the Reverend Al Sharpton they called for
police reform Nichols died last month
just days after he was brutally beaten
by several police officers and many of
those officers now charged with murder
have faced discipline we're told for
previous actions on the job Lee's
Preston is in Memphis with the latest on
that part of the story Elise good
morning to you tough day in Memphis
today
Gail good morning there's still so many
things the family doesn't know like what
started this traffic stop and why it
escalated yesterday the city of Memphis
announced it will likely be be weeks
before the full video and audio of the
incident is released to the public
Tyree Nichols his parents were joined by
the Reverend Al Sharpton yesterday in a
plea for justice and answers what were
they enforcing an even better question
what did they stop him for it came amid
Revelations that formed the five former
Memphis police officers facing murder
charges for nichols's death had previous
reprimands and suspensions Memphis
police files obtained by CBS news showed
that two of the officers Demetrius Haley
and Desmond Mills Jr both received
written reprimands for separate
incidents involving use of force in 2021
Haley grabbed a female suspect by the
arm after she allegedly resisted an
arrest he failed to file the required
paperwork afterwards Mills Jr received a
similar admonishment after he took a
woman to the ground as he arrested her
back in 2019. he also never filed
paperwork another one of the officers
emman Martin III was suspended for three
days after a gun was found in the back
seat of his patrol car after his shift
ended and Justin Smith was suspended for
two days for hitting another vehicle
while in an unmarked Cruiser anyone with
a suspension record like that should
certainly not have been on the fourth
Sunday night on an Elite Force as
nichols's family Mourns
[Applause]
the Memphis Community has rallied to
their side everyone deserves to survive
a traffic stop J Lawrence Turner is the
senior pastor at Mississippi Boulevard
Christian Church which will host
nichols's funeral today what is the
legacy of Tyree Nichols I think this is
going to be one of the defining moments
of the Contemporary civil rights
movement that his death will not be in
vain
now CBS News has learned that a 22 year
old man is planning to file suit against
the city of Memphis and the police
department monterius Harris says those
same five former officers beat him up
three days before the Tyrese Nick Tyree
Nichols incident involved also including
also involving another officer who is
involved in the investigation we have
asked the department for comment
meanwhile vice president Kamala Harris
plans to lead a group of Biden
Administration officials at today's
funeral David
at least everyone deserves to survive a
traffic stop what a quote
thank you